the pre-equilibrium approximation is
used to find the rate law for a
mechanism with a fast initial step as an
example let's look at the reaction
between nitric oxide and bromine
in the first step of the mechanism
nitric oxide combines with bromine to
form nob r2 and the second step of the
mechanism nobr2 reacts with no to form
our product 2nobr
nobr2 is generated from the first
elementary step of the mechanism and
then nobr2 is used up in the second step
since nob r2 wasn't there in the
beginning and it's not there in the end
we call nobr2 and intermediate
first step of the mechanism is fast
and the second step of the mechanism is
slow since the second step of the
mechanism is slow this is the rate
determining step and we can write the
rate law for the overall reaction by
writing the rate law for this elementary
reaction that makes up step two of our
mechanism so we can write the rate of
reaction is equal to
for step 2 our rate constant is k2
and we multiply k2 the rate constant by
the concentration of our two reactants
which would be the concentration of n o
b r two
and the concentration of n o
since the coefficients in our balanced
equation are ones for nob r ii and one
and a one for n o we can take the
coefficients and turn them into
exponents in our rate law so we can do
this because this is an elementary
reaction
however we can't leave the rate law for
the overall reaction in terms of the
concentration of our intermediate nob r2
it's preferable to have rate laws
written in terms of the concentration of
our reactants which were no and br2
so we need some way of substituting in
for the concentration of
nobr2 and we can do that by assuming
that the first elementary step in our
mechanism comes to a fast equilibrium so
if we assume the first step comes to a
fast equilibrium
we can use the pre-equilibrium
approximation
if we assume that the first step comes
to a fast equilibrium
or a pre-equilibrium we know at
equilibrium the rate of the forward
reaction is equal to the rate of the
reverse reaction so in the forward
reaction for step one no combines with
br2 to fo to form nob r2 and the reverse
reaction no nobr2 breaks apart to form
no and br2
so if the rate of the forward reaction
is
equal to
the rate of the reverse reaction
at equilibrium let's go ahead and write
the rate laws for the forward and the
reverse reaction
the rate constant for the forward
reaction is k1 so we can go ahead and
write the rate of the forward reaction
is equal to k1
and our two reactants are no and br2 so
we have k1 times the concentration of no
times the concentration of br2
since the coefficients in our balanced
equation are both ones for these two
reactants we can raise the power of
these two concentrations to the first
power since this is an elementary
reaction we can do this
and we set this rate of the forward
reaction equal to the rate of the
reverse reaction the reverse reaction
has a rate constant of k minus 1
and we have only no br2 with a
coefficient of 1 in it so we multiply k
minus 1 times the concentration of nobr2
to the first power
next our goal is to substitute in for
the concentration of our intermediate
and so we can divide both sides of the
equation by k minus one
so if we decide if if we divide both
sides of the equation by k minus one on
the right side k minus one cancels out
and we get that the concentration of our
intermediate nobr2
is equal to k1 times the concentration
of no to the first power times the
concentration of br2 to the first power
divided by k minus 1. next we can
substitute all of this in for the
concentration of our intermediate
that gives us the rate of reaction is
equal to we still have this k2 in here
so we have to make sure to include it
and we're going to substitute everything
in all of this in for the concentration
of our intermediate so that would be
times
k1
times the concentration of no to the
first power times the concentration of
br2 to the first power divided by k
minus 1
and then we still have this
concentration of no to the first power
so to make sure to include that in our
rate law
let's think about
what we would get if we multiply two
constants together and then divide by a
third constant so multiplying k2 times
k1 and then we divide by k minus 1 that
would just give us another constant
which we could just call k
so k is now the rate constant for the
overall reaction so we have the rate law
for the overall reaction is equal to k
times the concentration of we have no to
the first power times no to the first
power which is just the concentration of
n o to the second power
and we still have to include the
concentration of bromine to the first
power so now we have a rate law for our
overall reaction in terms of the
concentration of our two reactants the
rate of reaction is equal to the rate
constant k
times the concentration of no squared
times the concentration of bromine to
the first power
the experimentally determined rate law
matches the rate law that we found using
the
pre-equilibrium approximation
if you look at the coefficients for the
overall equation there's a 2 in front of
no and a 1 in front of br2 it might be
tempting just to say can't we just take
those coefficients and turn them into
exponents because in this case they
happen to match the exponents in our
rate law that's just a coincidence for
this reaction we can't just take the
coefficients for an overall equation and
turn them into exponents in the rate law
we can only do that for elementary
reactions like the elementary reactions
in the two steps of our mechanism
it's important to point out that if the
rate of the forward reaction is equal to
the rate of the reverse reaction the
concentration of our intermediate nobr2
remains constant and therefore we can
use the this pre-equilibrium
approximation to find the rate law for a
reaction with a fast initial step